et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Jean-François Copé bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être là mère les républicains
de mots en étant enfant pendant 20
minutes pour un interview en partenariat
avec la presse régionale représentée par
Christelle Bertrand du groupe La Dépêche
bonjour Christelle bonjour Ryan bonjour
Jean-François Copé on va évidemment
parler de la réforme des retraites et de
cette mobilisation hier mobilisation
importante c'est la plus forte des six
journées de mobilisation deux autres
sont d'ores et déjà prévu est-ce que le
gouvernement doit bouger sous peine de
voir le mouvement stradicalisé et il a
beaucoup bougé le gouvernement parce
qu'en réalité entre l'ambition initiale
de 17 milliards d'euros d'économies dont
on peut penser que c'était quand même la
manière de pérenniser une réforme et de
pas obliger encore à refaire une dans
trois ans mais il y a beaucoup reculé je
crains que malheureusement le compte n'y
soit pas enfin bon maintenant le le
cellier et c'est parti ils vont pas
s'arrêter mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'il est déjà beaucoup de concessions
de fêtes très tôt donc du coup il y a
plus grand chose à proposer pour
permettre à chacun de sauver la face se
demande les manifestants les syndicats
c'est la fin de 64 ans
on peut aussi prendre des choses à
l'envers c'est à dire regarder la
réalité de tes choses et ou plutôt que
de dire on ne veut pas de la date butoir
de 64 ans considérer les chiffres et se
dire que si on le fait c'est pas par
plaisir c'est tout simplement parce que
sinon c'est nos enfants qui n'auront pas
de quoi avoir de financement de retraite
c'est quand même pas un débat
anecdotique compte tenu de l'évolution
démographique si vous ajoutez à cela le
fait que dans tous les pays européens
tous sans exception l'âge de départ à la
retraite je parle des pays européens je
parle pas d'autres pays du monde on est
entre 65 et 67 ans passés à 64 ans nous
met encore les derniers en Europe c'est
pas par hasard l'exception personne dans
la rue il faut il faut pas toucher à ça
mais vous savez l'indicateur c'est pas
le nombre de gens dans la rue c'est le
nombre de grévistes parce qu'en réalité
ce qui on sait bien que tous les gens
qui sont dans la rue sont gens qui sont
en grève le jour où ils manifestent en
revanche ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir l'indicateur du nombre de gens qui
se font la grève parce que on n'est pas
payé pendant la grève et ce que je
constate c'est qu'il y a une baisse
assez significative partout par rapport
au pic du 19 janvier donc moi j'ai quand
même le sentiment oui à l'exception
telle ou telle service mais globalement
il y a une baisse très forte à Meaux par
exemple c'est quasiment moitié moins
dans les personnels de la de la mairie
de Meaux donc je vois bien quand même
que derrière tout ça il y a sort de
fatalisme quand même bien sûr que les
gens ils sont contre on a compris qu'ils
étaient contre ou plus exactement ils
savent très bien ce qu'est la réalité de
cette réforme mais ça les énerve parce
qu'ils ont pas envie de ça et plein de
raisons qu'on pourrait développer mais
peu importe donc aujourd'hui le vrai
sujet c'est que cette réforme elle doit
passer maintenant parce qu'on a on est
allé trop loin et quelque part trop loin
dans le sens de la nécessité de
l'affaire donc faut pas reculer c'est
l'intérêt de la France
a demandé à être reçu par Emmanuel
Macron il ne l'a pas fait pour l'instant
qu'il doit le faire aujourd'hui est-ce
que c'est normal tu devrais le faire
d'abord parce que quand on est présent
dans la République on doit jamais
refuser de recevoir des gens qui vous
demandent audience c'est le principe
même de la de la démocratie et du
rapport très complexe et en même temps
très très particulier entre le Président
de la République et l'ensemble de ces
concitoyens ou de ce qu'on appelle pour
aller vite les corps constitués et
notamment les partenaires sociaux donc
je pensais important de les recevoir y
compris avec une position ferme mais au
moins dialoguer jusqu'à présent moi j'ai
pas de communauté à faire je pense en
tout cas que ce serait bien qu'il le
fasse maintenant pas pour céder c'est
pas le sujet mais pour les entendre et
puis peut-être aussi pour essayer de les
convaincre est-ce que vous disiez que
finalement le compte n'y était pas sur
cette sur cette réforme qu'on a eu
beaucoup cédé financièrement est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui cette réforme vaut encore
le coup de mettre autant de personnes
dans la rue la semaine prochaine et de
continuer sur des journées de grève dont
on le sait que même si elles sont
de moins en moins importantes comme vous
le dites vont continuer encore quelques
il faut évidemment qu'il faut tenir il
faut tenir d'abord parce il y a quand
même une réforme le passage à 64 ans
c'est très important quand même
deuxièmement parce que il y a un certain
nombre d'avancées qui sont prévus
notamment pour les petites retraites il
y a un progrès qui est en train de
d'être accompli pour l'égalité des des
droits des femmes même si c'est pas
encore complet je vois bien qu'il y a un
effort qui est fait et tant mieux il y a
enfin
une décision qui a été prise sur les
régimes spéciaux bon la date enfin même
si c'est ce qu'on appelle d'un terme
bizarre la clause du grand-père matière
pour les nouveaux entrants enfin au
moins il y a eu cette marche qui est
franchit donc juste il faut faire sauter
cette clause du grand-père parce que
Bruno retaille lui dit qu'il faut
accélérer la suite
il y a au moins se cliquer là alors que
le rapport bon enfin voilà donc pour
toutes ces raisons et pour vous il faut
que lui dit 2040 64 ans totalement
raison encore une fois c'est
incompréhensible pour les autres pays
européens il y va de la crédibilité de
la France on n'est pas une île la France
est un des pays membres de l'Union
européenne les plus importants du point
de vue d'ailleurs démographique on est
regardé par les autres pays d'Europe on
peut pas simplement se dire on s'en
après nous le déluge etc sur cette
question des régimes spéciaux
pas mal la droite l'a pas fait donc
franchement faisons preuve un peu
d'humilité mais encore une fois il y a
eu beaucoup de recul le contenu n'est
pas complètement parce qu'il fallait 17
milliards d'économies et que on est
maintenant à 13 milliards et que ça
risque de descendre encore bon est-ce
que c'est pas aussi la faute d'elle
Emmanuel Macron voulait 65 LR ont plaidé
pour 64 Emmanuel Macron voulait
revaloriser les retraites des nouveaux
retraités les LR on peut l'aider pour
que ça soit une revalorisation de toutes
les retraites est-ce que c'est pas la
faute DLR s'il manque la faute
qui ont été faites qui à mon avis
étaient pas indispensables et et le
gouvernement en plus a fait le choix de
céder à LR ce qui était mal mais n'a pas
empêché quelques LR de pas jouer le jeu
quand même mais mais dans le même temps
vous n'aurez pensé que c'était pas mal
que le gouvernance cède au syndicat
c'était plus logique bon comme ça il y
avait au moins une sorte de de chacun
sauver la face bon enfin bref ça c'est
mal embauché dès le début c'est comme ça
mais
je pense qu'en réalité il fallait
fallait posséder autrement en fait je
pense que dès le début de ce quinquennat
Emmanuel Macron aurait dû être beaucoup
plus ouvert vis-à-vis de la droite
républicaine et proposer vraiment de
partager un certain nombre de
responsabilités parce qu'après tout
monsieur Macron il a pas la majorité
absolue il a jamais voulu l'entendre
mais c'est la réalité alors je sais bien
que quand on est présent dans la
République on n'a jamais été député
jamais été maire qu'on a été élu très
jeune que on a touché on est touché par
la grâce on pense que c'est pas grave
les autres bon mais si quand même on est
dans une démocratie donc ça aurait eu la
majorité mais en même temps il y a
jamais de proposition jamais de dialogue
j'ai jamais eu de rencontre je fais
partie de ceux qui disait mais au moins
parlons-nous c'est un échec total
personne n'a voulu parler à personne
c'est comme ça c'est la vie bon mais
donc c'était mal embauché dès le début
mais maintenant que nous en sommes là je
pense que elle est à se grandit en étant
à des acteurs clés de cette réforme et
c'est le cas et chapeau sénateur parce
qu'ils font un vrai travail et je pense
ça c'est majeur et on aura un
rendez-vous sur l'immigration dans
quelques semaines qui sera tout aussi
important donc encore une fois
maintenant tout ça est structuré je
pense qu'il faut que LR veut être cette
réforme parce que ne pas la voter c'est
être encore dans l'ambiguïté entre d'un
côté l'extrême droite et l'extrême
gauche qui est évidemment eu sont dans
une logique d'être opposés à tout pour
déstabiliser le pays et des macronistes
qui sont fragiles mais qui appliquent un
programme qu'on aurait dû appliquer
donc les manifestations vont
vraisemblablement continuer Emmanuel
Macron ne va pas céder en tous les cas
sur la mesure d'âge est-ce que vous ne
craignez pas une radicalisation du
mouvement dans les prochaines semaines
parce qu'une radicalisation c'est
toujours possible mais moi jusqu'à
présent dans les manifestations hier il
y en a eu est-ce que ça vous inquiète il
faut savoir une chose la radicalisation
c'est toujours le fait d'une minorité
cette minorité ce qui marque la
radicalisation c'est le fait qu'elle
porte atteinte à l'ordre public et donc
ça n'est plus un sujet économique et
social c'est un sujet d'ordre public et
d'autorité de la République donc là on
passe du coup dans ce qui relève de la
compétence du ministre de l'Intérieur et
il est évident que si il devait y avoir
des blocages massifs sur les routes les
les autoroutes les dépôts de carburant
et que c'était les enjeux stratégiques
du pays qui étaient en cause il faudra
et s'il ne le fait pas ce serait une
grave faute qu'Emmanuel Macron fasse
preuve de fermeté bon mais les blocages
mais dans l'hypothèse d'une de ce que
vous évoquez c'est-à-dire d'une
radicalisation par une minorité bon mais
encore une fois aujourd'hui ce qui
prévaut c'est pas ça ce qui prévaut
c'est une baisse du taux de grévise bon
et c'est pour moi le marqueur le plus
important c'est d'autre part le fait que
il y a des manifestants des manifestants
nombreux et c'est normal ceux qui font
grève ils vont plutôt manifester c'est
logique après une fois qu'on a dit tout
ça moi mon sentiment c'est que les
Français sont pas du tout content de
cette réforme on l'a bien vu mais je
pense que ils sont en train de passer à
autre chose au fond de je parle des des
Français tout court beaucoup d'entre eux
se disent bon toute façon c'est un peu
inévitable le gouvernement lâchera pas
d'ailleurs manuel Macron il a quand même
été élu là-dessus dans son programme ça
nous énerve mais on comprend bien que
quelque part il va falloir le faire il y
a une sorte de de comment dire de
conscience que de toute façon il pas
tellement d'autres choix quand on
regarde ce qui se passe dans les autres
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas d'abord
parce qu'en plus il y a quand même
d'autres préoccupations pour les
Français il y a un sujet de pouvoir
d'achat quand même majeur il y a quand
même un sujet géopolitique qui est
omniprésent qui est la guerre en Ukraine
et qu'on le veuille ou non ça a des
résonances y compris dans nos vies
quotidiennes du point de vue
psychologique aussi tout ça à mon avis
dépasse le seul sujet des retraites mais
par exemple les raffineries sont
bloquées aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il va
falloir si ça a perdu
réquisitionné par exemple on verra bien
on verra bien une étape après l'autre
moi je pense qu'à ce stade c'est pas le
sujet majeur d'abord dépôt de carburant
à une raffinerie c'est pas tout à fait
pareil et donc notre poids aujourd'hui
il est de voir l'état des lieux si c'est
une journée de journée la France peut le
supporter si on rentre on rentre autre
chose à ce moment là il va partira au
président de la République de prendre
ses responsabilités en matière de
République sur ce qui s'est passé cette
nuit au Sénat les sénateurs qui examine
donc l'article 7 sur le report de l'âge
de départ la gauche a quitté l'hémicycle
en raison de la volonté de Bruno
Retailleau et Gérard Larcher d'accélérer
les débats parce que eux arriver au bout
du texte vous partagez cette volonté
j'ai été bizarre là dessus avec le
Parlement j'ai essayé parlementaire je
connais toutes ces chansons là par cœur
à chaque fois on a l'impression que
c'est unique inédits on avait jamais vu
ça avant c'est toujours pareil la
plupart du temps c'est la conséquence de
ce qu'on appelle l'obstruction
c'est-à-dire que quand un gros
parlementaire dépose mis l'amendements
2000 amendements je suis désolé de le
dire vous les feuilletez les amendements
vous comprenez que 80% d'entre eux sont
stupides bon ils ne sont fait que pour
retarder par contre j'avais des
amendements structurants majeurs qui
peuvent faire évoluer les choses et qui
peuvent être l'objet d'un vrai débat
mais l'essentiel c'est pour faire durer
donc la logique c'est que d'un côté les
oppositions obstrues avec des
amendements stupides et de l'autre la
majorité dit bon écoutez on a passé le
cap on en a on s'en est tapé un certain
nombre idiot donc maintenant on va
passer à l'essentiel et donc on balaye
ses amendements pour aller à l'essentiel
c'est ce qu'on appelle le
parlementarisme rationalisé c'est une
invention de la Cinquième République
générale de Gaulle que pour ma part je
trouve excellente parce que sous
troisième et la Quatrième République on
a dévoyé le système parlementaire au
détriment d'ailleurs des parlementaires
eux-mêmes qui offrent une mauvaise image
aux citoyens
au niveau de l'opinion publique
d'accélérer comme ça artificiellement
les gens ils sont pas idiots ils voient
bien que ça dure des semaines et des
semaines il pensait même pour certains
que c'était déjà voté donc c'est vous
dire qu'on est loin de tout ça de ce
débat aujourd'hui honnêtement parfois
sont un peu cocasses et pour les
Français c'est pas leur priorités
avec le Parlement est-ce que le
gouvernement a fait une erreur de
limiter le temps de débat sur cette
réforme structurelle
d'abord la constitution de pair le
permet et heureusement qu'il l'a fait
moi je me souviens d'avoir eu les mêmes
sujets au moment de la réforme des
retraites en 2003 je parle de ça c'est
des veilles il y a très très longtemps
mais c'était déjà le même le même
scénario le PC le PS à l'époque avait
déposé des milliers d'amendements tous
plus crétins les uns que les autres
uniquement pour faire durer donc il y a
un moment on a dit bon écoutez tout ça
c'est bien gentil mais on va utiliser
les outils de la Constitution pour
raccourcir pour raccourcir le temps de
discussion et depuis on a imaginé
d'ailleurs depuis cette période d'autres
outils pour justement aller à
l'essentiel beaucoup de parlementaires
pensent qu'un débat est réussi parce
qu'on y a passé beaucoup de temps à
débattre de choses qui ne sont pas le
fond du sujet je pense l'inverse je
pense qu'un grand débat sur un temps
contrôlé mais où chacun a le temps de
s'exprimer de dire les choses est
infiniment plus intéressant pour
l'opinion publique quel regard vous avez
porté sur ce qui s'est passé cette nuit
au Sénat
mais c'est classique c'est un cinéma
pour vous oui non vous savez je pense
que le Sénat en ce moment donne une
meilleure image que l'Assemblée
nationale nous avons des sénateurs qui
travaillent d'ailleurs à la majorité
comme dans l'opposition qui font des
choses assez raisonnées chacun avec
leurs arguments ça n'a rien à voir avec
le spectacle lamentable de l'Assemblée
nationale ou véritablement nous voyons
des d'un côté député d'extrême gauche
qui qui en réalité salissent l'image du
Parlement avec des comportements qui
sont inadmissibles aussi bien d'ailleurs
dans certaines tenues vestimentaires de
t-shirts ou de jean troué que que sur la
sur le fond avec des propos insultants
qui n'ont rien à voir avec l'idée qu'on
doit se faire d'une des institutions de
ce pays quand même pour que le texte
soit voté avant Dimanche soir minuit
Gérard Larcher va peut-être devoir
utiliser le vote bloqué c'est un bon
scénario pour vous ce serait un choix
judicieux écoutez je pense que
l'objectif est que ce texte soit voté
au Sénat il n'a pas été à l'Assemblée à
cause de l'obstruction
pourquoi est-ce que c'est important
qu'un texte de cette nature soit voté
à l'assemblée
de toute façon orale prononcé pour ou
contre mais mais vous comprenez bien que
derrière ce sera l'article 49-3 si
jamais il y a pas de majorité pour le
voter ça d'ailleurs je souhaite bah non
j'espère que le députés LR veut ton
texte en nombre suffisant pour le faire
mais encore une fois il est capital
qu'un texte c'est important soit voté
par le Sénat et puis après par
l'Assemblée nationale c'est le vote qui
caractérise la décision parce que c'est
le moment où chacun dit oui ou non sauf
qu'il faut qu'il y a une cinquantaine de
députés LR qui le vote pour que ça passe
bien
j'ose espérer quand même que les députés
LR qui aujourd'hui marquent une
opposition à ce texte comprendront que
leur positionnement
et contradictoire avec l'engagement de
la famille politique à laquelle ils
appartiennent et sur laquelle ils se
sont fait élire est-ce qu'on peut la
convaincre et compris par la force qu'on
va Renaissance à dire ceux qui voteront
contre ou s'abstiendront ou ne seront
pas là seront exclus du groupe
Renaissance est-ce que j'en sais rien on
verrait bien mais
hier soir
vous êtes d'accord avec ça des
exclusions que quand j'ai exercé des
fonctions aussi bien comme président de
groupe d'ailleurs que comme président de
parti je n'ai jamais
je n'ai jamais voulu exclure pour des
positions de vote comme celle-là
peut le faire quand il y a des positions
qui sont contraires principes de la
République enfin là on n'est pas du tout
là-dedans il y a une certaine liberté de
vote quand même mais je pense en
revanche que il y a une logique il y a
une il y a quand même un impératif de
cohérence quand même quand on est élu
dans une famille politique d'abord on
doit son investiture à sa famille
politique quand même j'entends certains
amis LR dirait on s'en fiche du parti on
est députés on fait ce qu'on veut bah
ouais enfin toi quand même que tu es
investi que tu as une étiquette qui te
permet d'être élu c'est pas uniquement
ta tête est-ce que tu racontes c'est
aussi parce que tu as apporté une
famille politique sinon tu es pas élu
d'ailleurs les gens sans étiquettes à
l'Assemblée nationale quand ils sont
candidats ils sont pas élus donc il faut
quand même se rappeler de tout ça donc
le Paris celui qui donne Aurélien
Pradier clairement puisque c'est de lui
non pas il manque de loyauté mais pas
que lui enfin il faut pas se fixer sur
Aurélien mais ils sont proches ou pas
proches il y a tout un tout une série de
de députés y compris proches de Xavier
Bertrand y compris très proche de
Laurent Wauquiez qui considère que ils
ont pas voter ce texte bon moi je pense
que le faisan ils mettent quand même en
famille poétique en difficulté parce que
vis-à-vis des Français vous parliez de
l'image tout à l'heure moi je pense
c'est très important que elle reste un
parti de gouvernement un parti de
gouvernement c'est un parti qui prend
les décisions qui peuvent être
difficiles qui peuvent être contraire à
l'opinion du pays peuvent être impopuler
mais qu'ils sont nécessaires pour
l'avenir de la France vous citiez
Laurent Wauquiez il s'est très peu
exprimé sur cette réforme est-ce qu'il
doit le faire
plus fortement justement pour donner un
cap
il s'est fait exprès je comprends rien
du tout moi
donc il devrait parler pour moi
personnellement je me suis exprimé oui
très clairement comment vous l'expliquez
je suis pas psychanalyse toi
la politique ce silence c'est une
matière très noble la psychanalyse c'est
une matière majeure c'est ce qui permet
de comprendre l'esprit humain sa
complexité c'est une matière
passionnante et qui en politique comme
ailleurs est extrêmement utile
l'avantage c'est quand on a un peu
d'expérience on progresse dans cette
matière là aussi Aurélien Pradet puisque
il s'agit d'une rencontre ce matin
Laurent Berger le secrétaire général de
la CFDT avec une conférence de presse à
la sortie c'est un problème pour vous
c'est un choix qui vient confirmer sa
volonté de de mettre en difficulté sa
famille politique oui ça c'est
sûreté alors il a des mythes son poste
de numéro 2 mais est-ce qu'il doit aller
plus loin et sur des républicains en
réalité il y a le moment où quand on
quand on a ce type de le comportement
systématiquement hostile
on perd en crédibilité quand même voilà
je pense que c'est pas vis-à-vis d'un
parti c'est vis-à-vis d'abord de
soi-même et puis c'est vis-à-vis des
gens tout court qui regardent tout ça
même des gens qui sont au style ne
peuvent pas se reconnaître dans ce type
de démarche c'est pas estimable parce
qu'on voit bien que c'est un calcul et
donc je pense que c'est pas l'idée que
je me fais de l'engagement politique on
peut être contre on peut être rebelle
on a tous été d'ailleurs Pradier qui tu
t'es jamais vous l'avez été aussi oui
bien sûr mais en réalité c'est c'est pas
le fait d'être rebelle ou d'être hostile
ou d'être en différence c'est le fait de
choisir des combats dont on sait
pertinemment qui sont en contradiction
totale avec notre philosophie politique
oui il m'est arrivé
mais c'est faux en fait au nom de quoi
est-il incarne l'incargistre de la
Droite populaire
en étant contre une réforme des
retraites qui va protéger non seulement
les plus modestes mais les suivante mais
où a-t-il entendu ça depuis quand être
issu d'un milieu modeste comme c'est le
cas de millions de Français interdit à
ces millions de Français de ce
préoccuper de l'avenir de leurs enfants
enfin c'est quand même dingue ça c'est
ça qui ne va pas et qui n'est pas
logique donc en réalité le problème
n'est pas d'être en hostilité j'ai été
souvent en hostilité avec Sarkozy mais
je l'ai été sur des sujets dont je
conseille qu'à aucun moment je ne renier
mes convictions bien au contraire quand
j'ai dans d'autres temps imposer la loi
d'interdiction de la burqa dont je dis
ça parce qu'on est le jour des droits
des femmes et comme vous le savez
c'était une atteinte majeure au droit
des femmes j'avais contre mal hostilité
avéré et de Fillon et de Sarkozy bon et
j'ai considéré que avec mes amis députés
nous allions imposer ça parce que
c'était nos convictions profondes il y
avait une logique à ça bon donc c'est
pas la même chose que d'être hostile à
la réforme des retraites que nous
préconisons à droite depuis toujours
sans l'avoir toujours fait d'ailleurs
parfaitement donc là on a une étape
supplémentaire y être style c'est
incompréhensible pour les Français voilà
est-ce que ça se réforme à retraite va
laisser des traces au sein de la famille
des républicains ce qu'on voit qu'il y a
quand même eu trois positions très
différentes celle de réunir Pradier
convient d'évoquer celles directions
et celle des LR au Sénat qui ont pu
passer des amendements qui ne convenait
pas au gouvernement est-ce que comment
réconcilier cette famille non non parce
qu'en réalité il y a un alignement très
fort entre la majorité sénatoriale la
direction de LR ça va pas laisser des
traces pour vous et les carrières
longues
[Musique]
qui est des des idées un peu différentes
non non pour moi le vrai sujet c'est
entre ceux qui vont voter le texte et
ceux qui ne vont pas le voter voilà il y
a pas il y a pas 36 faut pas en rajouter
non plus c'est là que ça se passe mais
c'est un peu triste parce que dans cette
période qui est une très dure pour la
droite française qui n'exerce plus le
pouvoir national du fait des échecs
successifs que nous connaissons depuis
2012 on n'a pas besoin de ça en plus
quand même on va parler à un dernier mot
sur de la journée des droits des femmes
on le disait juste avant avec la
sénatrice vous êtes l'auteur co-auteur
d'une loi qui vise à imposer des quotas
de femmes dans les conseils
d'administration cette loi a plus de 10
ans maintenant Elisabeth borne présente
ce matin en conseil des ministres un
plan égalité homme-femme 2023 2027 on en
est où aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on est
encore loin sur l'égalité
vous faisiez allusion à la loi que nous
avons fait adopter avec mon ami Mario
Zimmerman qui prévoit la parité dans les
conseils d'administration des sociétés
françaises nous étions à 8% de femmes
nous sommes aujourd'hui à la parité nous
sommes promis au monde dans ce domaine
là et c'est la preuve que de temps en
temps les quotas c'est quand même très
bien parce que c'est ce qui permet
d'imposer des choses qui ne sont jamais
naturelles pour les hommes nous sommes
dans une société machiste et donc
évidemment que il fallait cette loi bon
je pense que de la même manière
progresser pour les comités exécutifs ou
les comités de direction des entreprises
c'est très bien après il y a des choses
ils vont quand même toujours pas je
pense en particulier aux inégalités
salariales dans le privé qui n'existent
pas dans le public puisque comme vous le
savez le statut de la fonction publique
et de ce point de vue remarquablement
républicain malheureusement du côté du
privé on en est très loin donc là ça
c'est pour le coup insupportable il faut
continuer de se battre dans ce domaine
et retraite aussi les femmes bien sûr le
Sénat a bien fait de de militer pour
justement rééquilibrer les choses et
c'est ce qui est en train de se faire
avec ce fameux bonus que propose Bruno
Retailleau tout ça me paraît vraiment
tout à fait bien après il y a encore
beaucoup de combats à mener et puis il y
a ce que nous vivons en tant que mère
nous au quotidien à travers les
violences intra-familiales qui sont
effroyables sur lesquels nous devons
être extrêmement sévères vigilant
organisé aussi bien répression qu'en
prévention et ce sont des sujets sur
lesquels bien sûr il faut être très très
mobilisé merci Jean-François merci
beaucoup Christelle de la dépêche c'est
la mobilisation record à Toulouse
manifestants contre 80 000 le 31 janvier
et on va en parler dans le club avec
Eric berger merci beaucoup comme dans
beaucoup de villes vous savez qu'il y a
beaucoup d'initiatives qui sont prises
nous nous organisons un grand forum pour
les femmes dans de mes professionnels
aussi citoyen et je pense que on ne dit
pas assez tout ce qui est fait dans les
mairies en ce 8 mars pour les droits des
femmes et vous l'avez rappelé au moins
pour la mairie de mon merci beaucoup
Jean-François Copé d'avoir été notre
invité